hey it's adam from wired uh welcome to
what i am calling the battle of the
action figure battles um i know that
everybody talks about comic con as being
a place where you see new movies and
maybe even comic books but i actually
have a
old nerdiness for action figures i was
the kind of person who spent a lot of
money on things like points of
articulation and
size relative to other action figures
and
different paint decos depending on
whether they were going on an arctic
mission or not i'm trying really hard
lately to not call them action figures
but call them dolls because
you know
they're dolls but
one of the things they do at comic-con
is that the companies who make the
main lines of action figures so like dc
comics and marvel comics will set up
these incredible tableaus where the
figures are all fighting with each other
like the kind of thing that i don't know
if you were someone like hypothetically
oh me you would have wished you could
build in your bedroom so what i want to
do is take a look at the marvel figures
and the dc figures and try to figure out
maybe who did them better or cooler
let's go have a look this is the marvel
display you can see that it's
enormous uh they have a huge castle set
up and like every comic book hero that
i've read in the last 30 years plus the
shield helicarriers floating up there
that's brand new everybody keeps walking
around the con bumping into people with
the giant boxes for it but the the level
of detail here is just astounding all of
the heroes are actually fighting their
arch enemies from the comic book
same thing like the deco is great the uh
the points of articulation are numerous
the everything poses like you can make
them pose in any position any person
would actually be in but it's got these
little like easter eggs for old nerds
like me like there's a dungeon down here
where
uh
where hydra
officers are experimenting on captain
marvel uh with flashing lights and
they've got instruments of torture and
then back here there's like a secret
hallway
room where all of the worst bad guys are
having a meeting with guns and money on
the table and dr doom is gesticulating
while at the same time up above
captain america just threw a shield it's
it's just kind of awesome and i talked
to the guys here and they um said
they're a bunch of custom pieces so in
addition to like giant sentinels walking
up through the water that you can
actually buy they were build a figure
things where you bought all the pieces
and put them together there's a giant
robot doctor doom that they built
special for this so just it's a huge
amount of attention i mean you can read
this thing like you would actually read
a real comic book okay so this is uh i
assume the central power battery on oah
these are green lanterns fighting with
various other colored lanterns i don't
know if you knew this but the lanterns
come in a whole bunch of different
colors and the rings mean different
emotions and different power sets i
won't bore you with all the details but
it's kind of cool there's uh hal jordan
fighting with i think atrocitus is the
red lantern there the central power
battery is where all the green lanterns
get their power the tableau the whole
backdrop isn't for sale they've been
saying that maybe they will put it up
for sale and you can see all the and the
characters like all the joints those are
points of articulation and you can see
like the double jointed knees so the
legs bend really well all the green's
really shiny that's deco the paint's
really cool so i mean it's a beautiful
set and they're all fighting the
appropriate enemies um and they all have
like the different lantern powers the
green makes flames for some of them and
guns for other ones so it's just
you know it's a cool set and everybody's
sort of expressing all of their emotions
right and then this one you want to
stand up or should we
look at that move look at that camera
move
and then this is all new justice league
so dc just rebooted the justice league
in the comics and uh the costumes are
all a little bit different i don't know
if you can see superman back here but
oh he's turned around superman doesn't
have the red underpants on anymore
batman doesn't have the black underpants
and you can see there's kind of armor
designs on the clothes and that sort of
design stuff is what a lot of collectors
really like about action figures when
you can see these little design details
that uh really pop maybe even more than
they do in the comics like uh
you can see the lines on flash's costume
or kind of differences in scale so that
the different heroes have different
bodies and that's dark side that big guy
is a big bad guy so this is a really
neat one too and then they're all
fighting on top of stuff wonder woman
and superman are fighting parademons
batman's up there um and you're supposed
to imagine that they're all caught in
mid battle
that's a nice one
well i gotta say as much as i think that
the dc figures are pretty awesome i
really like that marvel display that
castle man if they were selling that
thing i think that my wife would have to
talk me off the credit card cliff
let me know what you think put it in the
comments i think this one goes to marvel